schmeckt heftig Pansi was das kann ich
den ganzen Tag essen ohne alles auch
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben und willkommen zu einem
neuen Video bei dem wir wieder was mit
Hefeteig machen und diesmal werden es
richtig fluffiges soft-buns in Croissant
Form Leute das Endergebnis ist es wird
euch von den Socken gespannt
T mit dir später gerade bei dir du hast
mir so hohe Ansprüche was Hefeteig
angeht aber diesen ansprechen werden wir
gerecht ich gebe jetzt erstmal Milch in
eine ausreichend große Schüssel ich
hätte jetzt keine Milch mehr da und dem
Haferdrink könnte jetzt einfach ersetzen
man darf nicht Hafer Milch sagen man
muss dann immer Haar von Drink oder
Drink sagen so da kommt gezuckerte
Kondensmilch dazu wir brauchen übrigens
keinen zusätzlichen Zucker weil die
gezuckerte Kondensmilch ist ja wie der
Name schon sagt gezuckert einfach mit
zum Milch geben wie gesagt ihr könnt
auch normale Milch nehmen Fettstufe ist
auch vollkommen egal so und da gebe ich
jetzt Hefe hinzu entweder Trockenhefe
oder frische Hefe ich habe frische da
das jetzt rein bröseln meine Milch war
übrigens lauwarm habe ich kurz in die
Mikrowelle gegeben und die ganz genau
Mengenangaben mit Hinweisen stehen
sowieso immer unten in der
Infobox genau
lesen und gibt dann Mehl mit dazu ein
Tipp noch an der Stelle ihr könnt das
standardmehl Verwenden Typ 405 oder das
backstark nee das ist dann Typ 550 wenn
ihr das da habt
[Musik]
das entsteht jetzt ein Teig der erstmal
super klebrig ist an der Stelle geben
wir Butter dazu da könnt ihr auch
Margarine nehmen wichtig ist dass sie
total weich ist also gerne bei Butter 3
Stunden vorher aus dem Kühlschrank
nehmen und dann knete ich die jetzt noch
mit den Händen ein wir können an der
Stelle auch die Maschine also die Bakery
Box nehmen aber ich wollte euch heute
einfach zeigen dass es auch mit den
Händen geht
aber Hilfe Tag ist doch immer so das
muss noch ruhen jetzt oder ja also wenn
wir gleich schon mal die erste Route
generell finde ich Hefeteig braucht
immer viel Zeit und wenn man die
Ruhezeiten beachtet ist das Ergebnis
umso geiler also es ist nichts für Leute
die keine Geduld haben
[Musik]
so der Teig ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so
klebrig allerdings auch nicht trocken er
ist genau richtig wenn ihr quasi anfasst
und eure Finger bleiben nur noch zum
bisschen kleben aber ihr könnt sie lösen
ohne dass ihr Teig an den Fingern habt
also bitte nehmt nicht mehr Mehl als ich
ein Rezept angegeben habe denn sonst
wird er später zu trocken und wir wollen
ja so richtig fluffige soft Buttons so
und jetzt habe ich hier in der gleichen
Schüssel ein bisschen backtrennspray und
da würde ich jetzt auch kein Mehl unten
drunter stoppen und auch nicht oben
drüber weil das ist ja dann auch wieder
Mehl was sich in den Teig arbeitet beim
aufgevorgang und das möchten wir nicht
also der soll jetzt schön vor sich
hingehen und 45 Minuten lang auf jeden
Fall mit einem dicht verschlossenen
Deckel und ich habe noch einen Tipp für
euch also ich bin jetzt in der Küche mit
die ist alles offen total Durchzug quasi
und das ist eigentlich nicht gut für den
Hefeteig ich habe den Ofen nachher auf
30 Grad vorgewärmt und wer das ganze
darin gehen lassen also wenn Ihr auch so
ein Durchzug habt im Ofen wenn ihr nicht
30 Grad einstellen könnt
ja aber wir haben auch
eine offene Türen und so weiter das ist
das Problem und ihr könnt auch bei eurem
Ofen wenn ihr nicht direkt 30 Grad
einstellen könnt das konnten wir nämlich
bei unserem alten auch nicht Hamza da
könnte einfach auf 50 Grad ausmachen und
dann während der abkühlt erreicht er
quasi die 30 Grad aber wir sehen uns in
45 Minuten wieder haben sie du kannst so
lange Fußball weiter gucken
was für umständlich hier Filmen muss
vielleicht einfach nebenbei Fußball
Fußball
der Teig ist schön aufgegangen mal
gucken mal rein oh ja der sieht sehr gut
aus so und jetzt einfach durch 9 Teilen
warum fragt euch so einen ungerade Zahl
das brauchen wir deshalb weil das ja
gleich und unserem Backrahmen konnte
dafür brauchen wir heute abend ungerade
Zahlen und anschließend Rolle ich sie zu
Kugeln und zeige euch wie wir sie Form
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt Kugeln geformt und ich
habe jetzt einfach mal ein Tuch oben
drüber gelegt weil sonst trocknen sich
schnell aus und Hefeteig hat es ja immer
am liebsten wenn es gemütlich und warm
ist und ich nehme jetzt hier schon mal
meinen ausrollstark ich habe jetzt hier
die einfach nur vorsorglich die 2 cm
Abstandsringe drauf also ruhig sehr
flach gleich ausbreiten aber ich zeige
euch wie wir das jetzt shapen weil da
gibt's nämlich eine Besonderheit
fest so ich habe jetzt hier auch meine
silikonplatte und drunter dann kann doch
nichts ankleben so eine habe ich schon
vorbereitet zeige ich euch wie einfach
das funktioniert ihr nehmt euch einen
Teigling und ähm bereitet ihm erst mal
länglich aus also gar nicht rund sondern
schön lang nimmt euch einen Ausschlag
und dann rollen wir ihn von beiden
Seiten nach innen das hat nämlich gleich
also später nach dem Backen was mit der
Konsistenz zu tun
jetzt von beiden seit bis zur Hälfte
Rollen ihr seht dass der Teig sich noch
minimal zusammenzieht das ist normal
weil er sich gerade noch nicht
entspannen konnte nach dem Rollen dass
er dann quasi noch ein bisschen
entspannen musst auf jeden Fall braucht
ihr gleich ein bisschen Wellness damit
es schön fluffig wird aber erstmal bis
zur Mitte
so die andere Seite jetzt geht das
natürlich immer wieder auseinander daher
nehmt ihr euch jetzt äh Zeigefinger und
Daumen und dann einfach so zusammen
zwicken er hat mich ein bisschen am
Porsche
zusammen zwicken damit das zusammen
bleibt so und jetzt nach dieser
Ausgangslage nehmen wir uns wieder
unseren Teil Roller und müssen jetzt
quasi so eine Dreiecke was einfach nach
oben hin spitzer und breiter wird Formen
das Kind eher quasi von ganz normalen
Vorgang wie man dann Croissants macht
das ist einfach so eine Spitze hat damit
das auch richtig schick aussieht später
also oben breit und ein bisschen
schmaler genau unten schmal und spitz
und nach oben hin gerne wie so ein
Fächer also das ist oben richtig breitet
weil nur dann bekommt ihr diese schöne
und coole Croissant Form hinten kennst
du das manche Dinge muss man zeigen die
kann man nicht erklären
[Musik]
so die neuen Croissants wurden jetzt
geformt und jetzt kommen sie hier in den
Backrahmen das coole ist jetzt dass ihr
den Bagger mir verstellen könnt und ihr
wisst ja bei Hefeteig der hat ja ganz
schön Power wenn der aufgeht dann kann
es sein dass wenn im Backrahmen habt ihr
z.B jetzt nicht diese Klemmungen hat
dass der Backrahmen sich dann beim
g-prozess und beim Backen einfach
vergrößert und wir dann nicht das
gewünschte Ergebnis haben dann einfach
so einen tollen genau
verlinke ich euch natürlich so und jetzt
einfach die neuen Croissants hier
reinlegen mit ein bisschen Abstand denn
wir lassen sie gleich noch mal 30
Minuten gehen schön zugedeckt und dann
kommen sie auch schon im Backofen vorher
werde ich sie aber noch mal mit Milch
bzw in meinem Fall mit Haferdrink ähm
Pinseln und dann kommen sie in den
Backofen und werden schön fluffig
gebacken
[Musik]
meine Croissants waren jetzt bei 180
Grad Ober- und Unterhitze für 30 Minuten
im Backofen die sind noch richtig schön
warm und ich habe jetzt hier Butter auf
meinem Pinsel und jetzt einfach nur noch
für den Glow und für den Geschmack ein
bisschen einpinseln
[Musik]
und das fiese ist wir machen hier für
euch immer noch schöne endszenen und
Fotos für insta das ist so gemein ich
würde am liebsten jetzt direkt einmal
aufbrechen und Haselnusscreme drauf
machen
jetzt noch nicht schlimm hier ist das
gemeint ich will sofort essen haben sie
kommen wir machen jetzt N10 und dann
probieren wir jetzt zusammen
Fotos und dann wird gefuttert
[Musik]
obwohl du eigentlich gar keinen Bock
hast keine Ahnung hast ich bin ein
bisschen enttäuscht ne also du hast mir
getan
diese ganze Produktpalette hinlegen aber
der große Bruder war und ist immer die
Hazel Queen ja aber denkt doch mal die
kleinen Brüder ich bin auch einer von
den kleinen Brüdern ich bin der
zweitälteste Bruder ach so jetzt zwei
jüngste Bruder
so also ich habe jetzt hier schon mal so
für die N10 richtig viel hellgrün
draufgeben
ne eigentlich schon egal
das erinnert mich an Amerika gegessen
haben
wie heißt dieser Nummer
genau
gute
Kondensmilch ist schon ein bisschen
süßer ich nehme jetzt ohne cream aber
das ist sehr gefährlich das kann ich die
ganze Tag essen ohne alles auch
praktisch es ist so wie wie
Milchbrötchen aber oft sind
Milchbrötchen auch schon wieder ein
bisschen härter als das finde ich geil
ja ich finde es richtig fluffig also so
richtig und man kann sich das so richtig
hier so drehen daran sieht man halt
unsere teigtechnik von vorhin wo wir das
so nach halb eingedreht haben das macht
das Ganze auch noch mal fluffiger also
das ist immer so ein kleiner Trick ich
feier das übelst Leute übelst voll
hübsch
wir könnten das beide richtig alleine
Wasser kein Problem ich würde sagen wir
gönnen uns jetzt noch in aller Ruhe
Leute wer das nicht nachmacht der hat
wirklich was verpasst ich sag das oft in
mein Rezept aber das ist so ein Ding es
war auch gar nicht so super aufwendig
einfach Leute
Zutaten
wünschen euch noch einen schönen Tag
vergiss nicht meinen Kanal kostenlos zu
abonnieren also unseren Kanal ich bin
der Kiki und haben sie es kitchen und
zusammen sind wir dickes kitchen
auf jeden Fall wünsche ich euch viel
Spaß beim Nachmachen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video tschüss
[Musik]